here's leonard
finds morris extra pass jackson will
pull another three
and it's kawhi leonard he is fouled got
the offensive board he's whacked
doncic is down and limping that
left leg left ankle left calf
he injured that leg early in the game in
the
first game of this series
and he is down in a heap boy calls for
concern with that kind of reaction
[Applause]
unable to put any weight on it at all
man
that is frightening for the mavericks
oh man wow
say what that just looks awful
and with games every other day and i'm
not diagnosing what he has
but haven't had many ankle sprain
i'd bet anything now that is something
that's going to linger and you're just
going to have to
you know work with hopefully it isn't
serious and even if it isn't serious the
type of pain
uh the stretching that you have to go
through and then the trust you have to
build
again with your body jumping and landing
is just uh something that basketball
players have to go through all the time
seems more significant than just a
rollover is he and he's still
unable to put any pressure hopping up
that ramp
[Music]
this is not good 285 luca doncic will
return he's gonna give it a go here in
this fourth quarter we take you back to
game one
of this series this is early in the
series
that left ankle i mean this is in the
first couple of minutes of game one
and he was hobbled throughout the night
although he scored 42 points and then
the roll of the ankle right here the
left angle ouch
he limps all the way to the locker room
they send a wheelchair up there
he obviously brushes that off chris he
comes back and he's going to try to
give it a go in this fourth quarter i
mean come on are we really surprised i
mean
you know his passion again his
leadership
uh you expect him to be out there for
this team and by the way
he's having a great series he wants to
go get some buckets first two games
by dallas mavericks by 11 points so doc
rivers is trying to get
everybody back into it look uh just i
don't
i don't think he can keep going the pain
is intense you can see it in his face
now he just collected a triple double
with that dish
to finish smith he's got 13 10 and 10
but
this left ankle is biting him bad right
now
and on his way to the locker room with
athletic trainer casey smith
so luca's out nine minutes remaining in
regulation here and a
travel to michael green turns it over
they gave it a go
respect that he'll
exit with 13 10 and 10 and a triple
double his lowest scoring game in his
first playoffs